in this series and we surprise you and
you strip away any of the complexity and
hard graft and teach you how to cook
amazing food standing on your head that
is amazing incredibly tender from the
kitchen novice to the budding chef I'm
gonna give you the confidence the
recipes and the insider knowledge to
make you a much better cook slicer out
wasting nothing
I've been cooking in professional
kitchens for over 25 years what is
occurring now I've been taught by some
of the best chefs in the world and in
turn I've taught some of the best
[Music]
now I'm gonna show you some simple and
accessible recipes for fantastic food
that you can easily cook at home
ok I'll be holding you by the hand let's
get better and better and better teach
you everything from how to cook with
chili and spice to baking real fast food
and my ultimate beast recipes this is
the only cookery course we'll ever need
welcome to my optimal cookery course
with cooking tips information and 100
recipes to stay in your life on the
frying pan is one of your best friends
it's so versatile in the kitchen
learning to use it with these is a must
and I'm gonna show you how
first up my delicious pan-fried pork
chops with sweet and sour peppers
whether it's in the restaurant or even
at home one of my golden rules for
producing fantastic food is learning to
cook with confidence this recipe is so
straightforward but tastes absolutely
amazing
pan on get that nice and hot you think
of the sort of density of a pork chop
how it needs a little bit of health
sweet sound peppers don't burn any well
first slice the peppers that's the flat
side of the pepper so stand it up try to
slice a pepper on the side is a
nightmare there's the center start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange all the way around and down
and look this one
now place the pepper down three-finger
rule one thing you're in front two
behind pinkie holding it down thumb
holding it nice and flat the flat of the
vegetables the more confident you are
when you slice sir don't worry about the
speed just let the knife do the work and
take your time
speed tons the most important thing is
to get your technique right red onion
now sweet sour peppers olive oil in
[Music]
I'm going to sew to them which is just
the chef's term for shallow-fried on a
high heat for maximum taste
salt and pepper add a tablespoon of
sugar sugar helps to break down the
peppers quicker but caramelize the
onions find them in a frying pan perfect
there's one of those sort of basic
essential tools of any kitchen because
it's so multi-purpose great for sewing
tossing great for cooking fish and meat
push away and pull back push away and
pull back that hissing is something you
need to hear constantly because the
minute that's gone your peppers and your
onions start to boil and you really want
them to associate you now start to see
you listening in a way that it's time to
caramelize sugar is working usefully
that's ready pour the red wine vinegar
then
[Music]
smells incredible it helps sustain the
peppers as well but of the glaze now
these do the sugar
worked his magic turn down the gas and
out a couple of tables
extra-virgin olive oil let them stew for
two to three minutes
now I want to make the peppers nice and
light and sort of sweet aromatic just
roll the basil almost like a big cigar
slice
basil in and then literally cook it out
in 30 seconds and won them off
beautiful
okay turn back on and now for pork chops
I wanna make sure they don't curl up in
the pan they start coming up in the pan
they're gonna cook unevenly a few simple
cuts through the Rhine means the Chop
stays flat and cooks evenly
put the knife down
flip through this season of beautifully
nice large shards of pepper punch that
through lightly guaranteed that
seasoning is gonna stay there hot pan
Dutch garlic and such a time and the
garlic take a cup of clothes don't peel
it don't chop it just knife on
crush it
olive all in just startin to smoke top
of the chop in
lay away from
nice
keep that heat in the pan the garlic in
there early and I sprang a bunch of
thyme see how the pork is staying nice
and flat turn it over whether people
want a little bit of thyme underneath to
start squeezing that garlic out or what
the flavor coming out
butter in thin slices of butter tilt the
pan and baste
so I'm sort of speeding up the cooking
process at the same time I'm keeping the
pork chop really nice and moist and now
look at the color that butter it's
always those sort of I mean up Brown
check the color on the other side useful
when a that thick between 1/2 to 4
minutes each size very second from now
they're gonna be medium so I'm gonna
take them out and let them rest the
secret to perfectly moist pork chops is
letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in the pan
a nice spoon of these peppers basil
smells incredible did that garlic on
there be generous without vinaigrette
from the pepper because it really is
incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers and your conference is going to
shoot through the roof a stunning pork
chop with sweet sour peppers
the frying pan is so simple but
incredibly useful with this one pan you
can make a million different dishes the
more you cook with your fine pan the
more your confidence will grow here are
three my favorite easy pan-fried dishes
first up pan-fried scallops with crunchy
apple salad
get a fire pan smoking hot essential for
quick pan frying
add olive oil
then seasoned scallops with salt and
pepper
starting at the top put clockwise into
the pan so you know which one to turn
first
scallops have firm white sweet flesh and
cooking minutes
next salad lamb's lettuce
matchsticks with apple
seasoning
lemon zest and juice
[Music]
[Applause]
at Olive Oyl then toss
[Music]
turn the scallops when Gordon don't
clockwise around the pan
[Applause]
then squeeze in lemon juice and give the
pan a shake
finish with lemon zest
ready in under ten minutes my first pan
fried dish scallops with crunchy apple
salad
my next super simple pan-fried recipe is
chicken and chicory in masala sauce
[Music]
season the chicken breasts
add to hot olive oil skin-side down lay
away from you to stop the all splashing
sliced chicory this versatile vegetable
can be read all white has a lovely
bitter taste and is great cooked or raw
[Music]
crush a clove of garlic and add their
sprigs of thyme
when the chicken skin is crisp turnover
along with the chicory
for the sauce and masala a sweet
fortified wine from Sicily
[Music]
then 150 mil of chicken stock
to make the sauce wander too rich in
glossy and butter and simmer for 10
minutes
plate up and spoon over the sauce
cooked and under 20 minutes chicken and
chicory in masala sauce
[Music]
my final dish cooked in the versatile
frying pan is sea bream with tomato and
herb seller
fry phyllis of sea bream skin side down
in hot olive oil if they buckle up press
gently down for perfect even cooking
then season
sea bream has firm white flesh perfect
for pan frying
next the salsa
heat olive oil add half cherry tomatoes
pitted black olives and seasoned
[Music]
after a minute on a low heat add
coriander basil and lemon
[Music]
combined and leave to infuse
as a seabream cooks it goes opaque
when it's 2/3 on the top turnover
based fry and it's done
[Music]
seabream with tomato and herb salsa
ready in under 15 minutes
one pan free simple impressive and
absolutely delicious dishes beautiful
coming up on my ultimate cookery course
along with a hundred recipes to stake
your life on I'm gonna give you a
hundred quick cooking tips to make your
life in the kitchen easier
first up how to keep your knife sharp
it's far harder working in the kitchen
with a blunt knife than it is with a
sharp knife the secret behind keeping a
sharp knife sharpen it before and every
time you use it first grip the steel
feel really come to about holding still
imagine you're holding a tennis racket
or you're playing squash he's really
comfortable with it now 45 degrees
confident grip confident grip with a
knife this is the butt of the steel
really important to keep your fingers
behind that you never grip a steel with
your fingers over that because the knife
comes back in you just lost a finger
it's always grip behind nice long
strokes so we get the whole of the blade
over
steel stroke and we start from the
bottom to the top so there
across there across
throw strokes over the top of the steel
and then come back in to meet send back
underneath
it is so dangerous working in the
kitchen with a blunt knife you can cause
so much damage working with a sharp
knife is ten times quicker more
efficient now that's ready to start
chopping
- stop your chopping board rocking or
slipping a great tip is to simply wet a
kitchen cloth kitchen paper or tea towel
and place it underneath
now you can chop with confidence
my next top tip is get the most out of
your humble veg peeler it's brilliant
for slicing ultra-thin ribbons or veg
perfect for Asian dishes great for
making long delicate parmesan shavings
to top soups and salads it also makes
wonderful chocolate curls
[Music]
your Peppermill is more versatile than
you might think
tighten the top screw to get finely
ground pepper ideal for soups and sauces
for general seasoning you want it medium
ground to set the screw in the middle
and loosen it right off for coarse
pepper perfect for steaks and fish
[Music]
peeling garlic the one clove simply bash
it with the back of a knife and the skin
comes off easily
for a whole head crush seperate into a
bowl
cover and shake hard for about ten
seconds
then simply pick out the pill cloves
[Music]
coming up on my ultimate cookery course
more great cooking tips just hold it
down and your fingers on there's a
really nice way of taking off all those
nice fragrant little thyme flowers how
to shop for the best ingredients your
skin is a nice white color and it smells
like a fresh chicken a smell and a
stunning roast chicken recipe to stake
your life on
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on I'll be
showing you a roast chicken recipe to
die for hold the drum the sliced a
through but first like any good chef I'm
always looking to get great ingredients
at the right price my shopping mantra is
simple first rely on your senses make
sure whatever you're buying it looks
smells and really feels good as you get
the chance taste it before you buy it
second is to recognize that knowledge is
crucial the more you know about where
your ingredients come from and how they
produce the better so asked lots of
questions and learn
you're never too old to learn from
experts and when it comes to buying
great birds the one person knows what to
look for is award-winning
fifth-generation master butcher Danny
Lydgate
poultry is a great meats because there's
many different types of birds it's worth
tasting the variation of flavors between
different first two firs is massive
Turkey's a great lean meat that's
available all year round not just for
christmas anybody who's worried about
eating fatty meats it's a really healthy
flavorsome meal game birds people don't
try them often enough once their shots
they're hung up for a little while a few
days at least it means the meats going
to be more tender all adds of flavor to
the birds we've got a wood pigeon and a
red leg Partridge both really good and
cook really quickly
when you're buying a chicken some of
things to look out for is obviously the
smell and when you're smelling a good
quality chicken you can tell the
difference the skins are nice white
color and it smells like a fresh chicken
II smell
when you're buying from a good blood
show you'll find you tend to get the
giblets as well which is basically the
neck and other organs this is great for
making gravy once you have cooked it you
can use all the offcuts for other things
stir Fry's Curry's pass the dishes save
the bones use the bones for stocks and
soaps a really packed full of flavor and
remember there are lots of different
breeds of chicken all have different
characteristics and flavors so shop
around and find the ones you love here
are three of my all-time favorites the
label Anglais these come from an old
British breed they've got smaller
breasts but the meats delicious
the black leg a fantastic French variety
succulent with bags of flavor and really
meaty thighs and the pulley device this
is the rolls-royce of chickens rich
gamey and delicious one for special
occasions
I
think people should maybe try and buy
less meat but aim for the best quality
you're only going to get out what you
put in by putting the best quality into
a dish you're going to get the best
results
no matter how seasoned the chef you are
there are always new ingredients and
recipes to get fired up about
so if a tired old recipe is getting you
down spice it up with fresh ideas and
flavors
my next recipe is an old classic roast
chicken but with a simple twist it takes
on a new life and is guaranteed to
impress
one of the things I love about cooking
and that keeps me excited after 25 years
behind the stove is that there's always
something new to learn every day new
ingredients new techniques and new
cuisines
start off with a stuffing it's amazing
how exciting I stuffed roast chicken can
be because it keeps the chicken
incredibly moist and gives a delicious
texture inside the bird I'm going to
start off with cured sorriso this is a
traditional Spanish sausage and it's
garlicky spicy
incredibly meaty that gives a little bit
of sort of richness to the stuffing get
our Reaser in
start cooking that down and get all
those oils out a touch of olive oil in
there to get it going right onions
chopped
add the onions to the Sarita and in a
matter of seconds they'll change color
as they soak up all the flavor but
lovely spiciness has been stolen from
that sausage now the onions smell
incredible
garlic
garlic in fresh thyme just hold it down
and your fingers on there it's really
nice why I've taken off all those nice
fragrant little thyme flowers you can
hear it crackling in the background
these are kyleannie beans in their waxy
very soft and so delicious bubbling very
dense but for stuffing they're so robust
nothing breaks down drain them off
in
they're going to take on all that juice
as well from this freezer or season now
because if they dense so need some help
that looks like it's a dish on its own
I'm good enough to eat now or sweeten
things up a little bit
tomatoes half tried in that sweetens up
the stuffing
beautiful the stuffing is ready look at
the color everything but Spanish it
looks delicious now stuffing the chicken
I like taking off these little knuckles
as the chicken cooks the skin stretches
over the bone you can get a really nice
drum and take off those little wing tips
as well salt pepper
so important
now your stuffing we go right inside
which you can push it down this really
helps to cook the bird evenly because
you're pushing out all the empty spaces
in the carcass and take a nice large
lemon push the lemon in pick up the
parcels nose put the skin over olive oil
on top
salt and pepper
teaspoon of paprika
sprinkle it on and then put your hands
sort of rub that in you see what the
paprika is doing to the chicken put this
like sweet spicy marinade its lightly
roasted yet but it looks delicious
[Music]
400 mil of wine while same quantity of
water that helps the chicken to steamed
chicken in
be generous with the thyme sprigs
[Music]
make sure the fall is folded tightly
around the roasting tray so the chickens
themes in the oven keeping it moist and
juicy into the oven
[Music]
cook for 1 hour at 180 degrees with a
foil on nice take it out and remove the
fall lid then give it another 30 minutes
to crisp up that skin
[Applause]
it's so important to make sure you tear
that tinfoil off with half an hour to go
beautiful pierce the open squeeze it in
that delicious gravy mix that into the
tray
and
sip that
that's a really nice fragrant lemony
spiced roasting juices to finish before
we cut up the chicken take out an
amazing stuffing
mm-hmm
incredible I'll have that which you can
/ potatoes any day and then just get
your chicken roasting juices
now to cut the chicken out
hold the drum the slice straight through
and there's a wonderful drum and a thigh
through the wishbone
off
slice with the point at an angle so you
can see the texture that amazing roast
chicken just take my cooking juices so I
give you nice sort of lemony flavor
over my chicken and there you go a
delicious very charming stuffed roast
chicken
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and a
hundred recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef many of these amazing
recipes are on my app please check out
the App Store for details go on get
cooking